[Music]
you gained weight for this role is that
right I did they didn't ask me to I
don't think they wanted me to it was
thinking greatness in heroes like 25
pounds heavier like I'm ready for it
happened how did you gain all that
weight well they brought us down there
like three weeks why are down there
welcome easy Ana Louisiana uh and those
people in Louisiana know how to eat and
drink they're pros yeah so I decided to
go pro and I thought Easter's were like
fantastic for you they're horrible
there's so much fat and calories in
oysters and I kept calling them this
salad of the sea right in order a dozen
before every meal and so it all went to
my head - I have this they shoot you
know how they shoot movies I shoot him
like out of order we're like one scene
at the end of the movie we'll you'll
shoot it at the beginning
so like when one scene I'll have a
normal dude head and then in the very
next scene I'll have this giant
orangutan
melena at a big boom yeah yeah and for
some reason it did something to my hair
like my hair follicles got a little fat
too so like one curl would come down and
I just have a weird Superman that's
gonna be weird so your head is
contracting and expanding throughout the
movie very bizarre it's like a beating
heart yes yes it's the most compelling
reason to see a film I bet even if you
don't like the movie see it for that
yeah even if you're like Simmons not for
me for my head fat there's a I was
tricked about something you was reading
some of your tweets you tweeted recently
about pot and I was just curious like
you've mentioned your parents did your
parents when you tweeted about it know
that this is a something you've
experienced yeah well I do know they uh
yeah read your Twitter they do now and
they've seen the show but I would my mom
was sooo is very naive so I would always
just blame it on my friend I mean when
you win when she would as a kid I got
caught like a half-dozen times like just
because I was a stoner so I had to have
weed in my pocket which is a horrible
place to hide your weed kids box or
something I have a hole in your yard not
your front pocket so I would always my
mom would be like what is this what is
this I'm like I don't know where'd you
find it and she's like your pocket and
I'm like Kyle Walsh probably put that
there and you know I'm gonna own 50
bucks if I don't give that back to him
yeah you couldn't just let it go and
then and then every time she'd be like
well okay I'm like you don't want to
give me $50 do you I don't have that
kind of money just laying around alright
and should give it back to you yeah and
my dad knew what was up he's like yo ya
reefer baby put the pitchfork down you
have a we have a pitch-perfect clip from
the movie here I believe that you're
you're you're hitting on someone in the
scene yes
rebel Wilson and I have a lust affair in
the film and this is where I try to kiss
her let's see this clip they perfect
here's the real question who would be
easier to sleep with Captain America or
a great white shot
they weren't sharking what do you Ted
Baek is talking about dressing for
comfort you are probably the grossest
human being I've ever seen oh yeah my
panty jumping yourself so I have a
feeling that we should kiss and is that
feeling a good feeling or an incorrect I
sometimes have a feeling I couldn't do
crystal meth but then I think mm better
ah yeah
she's terrific